huge cultural news on this most sacred
liberal Festival of national coming out
day
64 year old pop singer Madonna
has come out as gay
here she is on Tick Tock says if I miss
I'm gay and she throws her underwear and
it misses and then she kind of throws
her hand in the air
to say that she is gay incredible news
that Madonna is finally accepting her
true self
her most authentic identity is gay we
just didn't know all this time but
that's her true self
incredibly it is incredible because
Madonna has famously dated lots and lots
of men
Tony Ward Sean Penn Lenny Kravitz Tupac
Dennis Rodman Carlos Leon David Blaine
Vanilla Ice Guy Ritchie A-Rod Brahman
Saibot Timor stefans ala Malek Williams
those are just the first ones that pop
up on Google in the first result on
Google okay
she's been married twice both times to
men obviously and I don't mean to
broadcast the lady's Secrets but they're
not secrets this has been her brand for
over 40 years
if Madonna is a lesbian this would
appear to be a rather recent turn of
events
but the LGBT activists tell us or at
least they used to tell us until very
recently that sexual orientation is
something that you're born with that
it's completely unchangeable that's why
we have to ban the so-called conversion
therapy
until the last few years
when not only sexual orientation but sex
itself became something that changes
constantly and however it changes
whenever it changes
that is your true authentic self until
tomorrow when it will probably change
again and then no one can ever bring up
all the stuff that you said and did the
person that you were just yesterday
National Coming Out day is the perfect
holiday for a culture devoted to erasing
its past to denying its Traditions to
maligning everything that happened
before this very moment a culture that
insists upon questioning every ancient
truth and bans you from questioning
anything that happens to be in fashion
among the ruling Elite right now
National Coming Out day is not the only
sacred liberal Feast that we're
celebrating this week I should have
spoken more about this yesterday I
forgot it's it's now it's the most
important it's the most important
liberal sacred holiday of October 12
2022. that of course would be
indigenous people's day
yes no that was it was I'm sorry it was
October 10th today is the 11th National
Coming Out day tomorrow I don't know
what's tomorrow going to be transgender
awareness day but yesterday was
indigenous people's day
also known as Columbus Day Columbus Day
is a real holiday that we have
celebrated off and on since 1891 1892
uh but it certainly since the 1930s
we've celebrated it very regularly until
a bunch of liberals decided that the
hate Christopher Columbus because he
discovered America and he brought
Christianity and western civilization to
the new world and they've decided this
is very very bad even as they sip their
Starbucks lattes and type on their
iPhones and enjoy all the Privileges of
being an American they pretend that they
would rather live under the Aztec empire
having their hearts ripped out by
Maniacs on top of a pyramid so that
that's what they tell us and it's not
just the Fringe people telling us this
that's what Kamala Harris tells us
the vice president tweeted out yesterday
on indigenous people's day we pay
respect to tribal Nations and Indigenous
history today and every day let us
continue to celebrate and uplift the
rich contributions of indigenous peoples
their leadership has made our country
stronger
now of course this doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense because we are told
on the one hand the indigenous peoples
are so important they've made our
country stronger or there's such an
important part of our country also we're
really really evil because we killed all
the indigenous peoples so which is it do
they still exist and they make our
country stronger did we kill all of them
and that's why we're so bad who are the
indigenous peoples that we're talking
about is when I think about the arrival
of Columbus 1492 Columbus hailed the
ocean blue he arrived and it's true that
this experience of what of colonialism
uh had some problems with it there's no
question about that although it's worth
correcting the historical record most of
the things that people accuse
Christopher Columbus of having done he
just didn't do it was other people it
was other Spaniards in fact Christopher
Columbus very often was taking the side
of the Native Americans against some of
the more aggressive and violent of the
Spanish conquistadors and explorers the
original crew not not the later cruise
but the original crew that came with
Columbus and actually a lot of the
crimes that he was accused of
he was accused of them by Francisco de
bobadilla who was his political rival
and who took over his spot as governor
of the West Indies so
yes it's it's
true that there is essentially one
document that says that Columbus did all
these terrible things but it was written
by his chief political rival that would
be like trusting an account of Donald
Trump's life written by Joe Biden that
just wouldn't make a whole lot of sense
and uh and in fact he was he he was the
victim of a whole lot of Calamity but
forget about that let's say that
Columbus did every single thing that
they said that he did
all of the crimes that Columbus is
accused of in his entire life
do not equal the horrors and crimes of
one four day period in 1487 at the
consecration of Tenochtitlan when the
Aztecs ritualistically slaughtered an
estimated 84 000 people
young people women ripped their still
beating hearts out of their chests and
kicked their bodies down the side of the
Temple
this four day period and it wasn't just
the Aztecs yes the Aztecs were
particularly nasty and yes when the
Aztec Empire was overthrown the
conquered peoples who were frequently
sacrificed by the Aztecs celebrated of
course they would have but it wasn't
just them it was the carob Islanders the
carob Islanders who who gave us the word
cannibal
the word cannibal in our language comes
from the carobs because they were
cannibals and they did all sorts of
crazy things and when Christopher
Columbus arrived in the new world he met
this nice group of Indians called the
tainos and some of them had marks on
their bodies
the marks were from the Caribs who were
complete Savages and it wasn't just the
carobs by the way going all the way up
into North America all the way up into
Upstate New York the Iroquois practiced
cannibalism
that so many of the Native American
tribes practiced cannibalism
Christopher Columbus for all his sins
the man never ate people okay and so why
do we celebrate indigenous people's day
if you're comparing Christopher Columbus
and the indigenous peoples qua the
indigenous peoples them as a people
Columbus was a zillion times better than
they were they did crazy stuff they
worshiped demons and and slaughtered one
another constantly and then ate their
bodies you know the the carob Islanders
raised babies to eat human babies and
they consider that a particularly tooths
and morsel according to the biography by
Samuel Morrison who's one of the most
respected historians in America
in American history
so no there's no comparison here
I I hate to put too fine a point on it
but Tony Soprano got this exactly right
his history teacher Mr Cushman is
teaching your son that if Columbus was
alive today he would go on trial for
crimes against humanity like milosevic
and you know Europe
your teacher said that it's not just my
teacher it's the truth it's in my
history book
so you finally read a book and it's
[ __ ] Tony
foreign
Columbus's shoes to see what he went
through
people thought the world was flat for
crying out loud
then he lands on an island with a bunch
of naked Savages on it I mean I took a
lot of guts
you remember when we went to Florida the
Heat and those bugs well like it took us
to murder people and put them in Chains
he was a victim of his time who cares
it's what he did he discovered America's
what he did he was a brave Italian
explorer and in this house Christopher
Columbus is a hero end of story end of
story absolutely true but that's not the
end of the story for the Liberals now
Robert Reich who is that sort of
diminutive fellow who worked in the
Clinton Administration he goes on cable
news sometimes very left wing he said
get Columbus Day out of your vocabulary
today is now indigenous people's day
and why who cares it's just a holiday
right who cares the libs care the libs
care a lot they focus a lot of time and
energy and money on getting us all to
hate Christopher Columbus and take down
his statues and to celebrate the
indigenous peoples we're going to have
Aztec 10 octetland day or something why
because it is a sign of cultural
conquest and political Conquest
because it is a song Because human
beings need holidays and and liturgy
human beings need order to their lives
what we celebrate what we worship
defines our culture
and uh previously we were a confident
culture we celebrated the man who
brought Christianity to the new world
the man who wrote European civilization
to the new world the man who gave us our
traditional country who started the
chain of events that led to our
traditional country the libs hate all of
that
and they finally amassed enough
political power that they seem pretty
able to blot it out
you Google what day is it on October
10th this year you Google it it's going
to say indigenous people's day you talk
to the Democrat Party they're going to
say indigenous people's day you talk to
your teachers you're going to say
indigenous people's day
they they have conquered that holla it's
a sign of a conquest not of the Native
Americans not of the new world it's a
conquest of you and your country
the rest of the show is continuing now
you do not want to miss it okay I'm
bringing on the man that I'm playing
fantasy football this week that would be
Jake crane of crane and Company I made
the huge mistake of allowing my producer
Ben Davies to choose my fantasy football
team which is why I think I'm in dead
last right now so uh for some reason I'm
still making another bet on whether I'll
win this week I'm assuming I'll probably
lose this one last time I lost I had to
electrocute myself on camera who knows
what we'll do this time be sure to head
on over there the member block begins
right now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]